et nous accueillons l'autre terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir lucienne moreau
[Applaudissements]
un rationnement bonsoir la population
vieillit ces stars aussi la preuve
lucienne aujourd'hui tout le monde
connaît cette vieille dame au look
déjanté définitivement banque devenue
l'égérie du petit journal à plus de 75
ans mais qui êtes vous lucienne d'où
venez vous qui étiez vous avant de faire
marrer les bobos de la fashion week vous
me raconterez votre histoire à 20 heures
[Musique]
lucienne mort bonsoir
alors vous êtes né le 17 février 1933
arena faisait en mayenne vos parents
étaient paysans et celle et moraux comme
chez les ingalls tous les enfants mettre
la main à la pâte pour faire tourner la
ferme
vous dites on était pauvres mais heureux
ah oui ça on était heureux alors en 1939
vous avez six ans et c'est la guerre et
votre père alphonse moreau gloire du
soir en u qui a fait 14 18 vous rassure
jacques envoyer les avions ne sait pas
trop ce que si les jeux tout cas à vous
quand ils les avions en ciel votre père
alphonse lui connaît la guerre déjà
il avait tellement vite chose que
ralph ont- ils cachent des gens nourris
des gens mais jamais de marché noir
voilà alors votre père mourra à cause du
gaz moutarde à parce qu'il avait fait la
guerre de 14 18 dans les tranchées ils
avaient été intoxiqués au gaz moutarde
qui est interdit d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
il mourra 55 ans que très jeune et vous
à l'époque vous avait neuf ans ouais à
cause de la guerre
mais c'est comme ça
alors certificat d'études dans votre
canton vous êtes 4e sur 200 c'est bien
voulait devenir professeur
nous on était nombreux et où ma mère
étant resté seul et il fallait qu'on
travaille pas mais voilà je n'ai pas pu
faire de longs détours de quoi alors
vous retourner aux champs vous marier à
19 ans fait un premier enfant
et au deuxième enfant vous réalisez que
ces histoires de ferme ça va vous
rapporter beaucoup d'argent un bail pas
banon c'était beaucoup de travail pour
ce que ça rapporte quoi et là vous
ouvrir une épicerie oui je vous vois un
bar à laval à laval mais dites moi vous
faites un mètre cinquante d'eux vous
quelque chose comme ça oui à 52 53
millions 53 vous faire plaisir l'hygiène
mais oublié quand y avait de la baston
dans le bar lounge et comment alors
moi j'étais énergique en fallait faire
la part des choses 1 celui là il y avait
trop
vous sortir les gens tout à fait avec
votre mètre cinquante de quoi oui la
grandeur
ensuite vous remariée avec un tunisien
vous partez vous installer à lille vous
travaillé dans le textile mais là les
entreprises ferment sais
comment c'est fait commencé à aller mal
voilà il avoue devenue infirmière en
fait ben oui sans diplôme diplômés à
cette époque là ça a marché comme ça
et alors ça marche très bien pour vous
parce que quand vous êtes infirmières
votre sympathie et votre sens de
l'humour fonctionne très bien
une bonne femme chapelle madame menu une
grosse
lui prenait pas
le seul problème c'est votre votre
ex-mari numéro de l'ats le tunisien il
repart en tunisie avec les enfants
compliqué ma vie quand même il faudra
huit ans avant que les enfants
reviennent en france
évidemment vous avez souvent en tunisie
dont ça vous coûte de l'argent oui c'est
plus les avocats oui c'est vraiment la
crise et donc vous devenez veilleuse de
nuit voilà dans un hôpital voilà quand
je suis redescendu chez moi voilà
et puis le 1er mai 1987 vous prenez
votre retraite oui et là vous découvrez
que vous avez 800 euros par mois elle va
pas chercher loin passer un sale moment
ça qu'est ce qu'on fait les puissants
euros par mois rien
pas grand chose alors la fête des
ménages oui je garde des enfants oui et
anti supplément koala puis c'est là
entre deux que j'ai téléphoné cette
annonce et voilà un jouet résister dans
un journal recherche figuration voilà on
vous dit pourquoi pas alors c'est génial
quand même à wissous ça j'ai toujours
provoqué mon travail mof voulait faire
de la figuration à l'époque c'est pour
l'ouverture de la ligne du rer e il
avait 67 ans à l'époque et nous fait de
la figuration pour l'inauguration de la
ligne voilà c'était bien d'ailleurs
voyez vous dites c'est mon boulot on est
payé pour s'amuser quoi oui pour moi
c'était ça par rapport au travail que
j'ai fait avant bien sûr alors là vous
êtes repéré par nos amis de groland oui
le canal plus et vous dit pourquoi pas à
une condition c'est que vous refusez le
nudisme du ciel
c'est dommage mais bon voilà et là c'est
le début de la célébrité vous devenez
femme d'affaires d'adapter très vite au
show business vous gérez vos contrats
faisaient un assistant oui de 2010 à
2012 le petit journal de yann barthès et
laurent bon ne jure que par vous vous
devenu l'art et jerry tout à fait là
vous affirmer comme une vraie pinder
vous avez le le blouson là c'est fait
rester en ut puisque j'ai fait le
tournage aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu le
temps de changer
il a donc vous êtes une vedette ou
passer vos soirées et jean paul gaultier
il sympa jean-paul ah oui rennes est
sympa je crois est ouais vous a pas
encore fait défiler mais ça va venir
ouais je pense je pense d'aller titiller
pour jean-paul c'est normal
après d'un lycan bel
et bien vous allez au festival de cannes
aussi ah oui c'était vraiment la
rencontre des choses que je n'aurais
jamais vu autrement fois sur deux
montées des marches oui oui bien sûr oui
j'ai fait des soirées à cames un peu
chaude oui
oui oui principalement une wii
à l'alcool des pétards et de la cocaïne
non j'ai cherché la cocaïne c'était une
belle soirée était d'accord
vous faites aussi la veuve fashion night
déguisé en lagerfeld alors qu envoyer 10
à rajoub dit celui-là j'en fais bien mon
4h01
fallu présenter un service
info-santé ben oui ah oui c'est vrai
c'est un basque vous ne connaissez pas
visage ou un peu ça peut s'arranger
lucienne vous êtes dans le bon endroit
ici
alors la seule la seule qui était pas
très sympa c'est bernadette chirac
elle est spéciale quoi
sinon à part ça au chili lé au graff
toute la journée et alors lucienne cette
nouvelle vie vous la kiffer à donf
hélas à 81 ans vous attaquer une
nouvelle carrière radio un courrier du
coeur très chaud un très très chaud sur
virgin radio
et la nuit vous faites la fête ça vous
coucher tard
ouais
vous fait la teuf
toute la nuit a relevé une phrase que
j'avais envie la vie est belle quand on
sait l'employé je veux vivre au moins
jusqu'à 100 ans mais c'est tout le mal
qu'on vous souhaite à tous les coups
alors demain c'est la fête des
grands-mères et je dois vous dire que
tout le monde d'avoir une grand mère
comme voulu ciel
[Applaudissements]
non merci
symbole
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus